(upbeat music)
- New intro life.
New intro life on "Tea With GaryVee",
super excited to be here.
Yeah, new camera, looking
down a little bit more so,
bear with us on that.
- I think I meant for
a sec 'cause it's like,
the feed's coming in a little
wrinkly.
- Is it?
- Yeah.
- What do you mean?
- I think it's just your
internet connection.
(slurps)
- From, I mean, it's always the same.
So, you mean like,
it's just blurry?
- Yeah.
- You wanna switch over to the other mic?
- Let me see what happens here.
- Okay.
- I guess I could ask the
people in the comments.
Not blurry for them, all right, whatever.
- Really, 'cause I think,
I think some people are saying,
some people think spotty.
Let's see, that's better.
- Yeah, it is clearing up now.
- Is it?
- Yeah.
- Looks good, you're fine.
- I mean, I guess,
if it gets bad, I'll
just come back in again
and just switch the camera or something.
- Alright, looks good.
It's blurred, maybe it's
blurry on some platforms.
(laughs)
- I mean, the comments
might be coming in delayed
so, they might be seeing
the blurry before.
(slurps)
- We'll just fucking go.
Morning, everybody, hope
everybody had a good weekend.
Let's go into the show.
- Hi, Gary.
- Hey Michelle, how are you?
- Good, how are you?
Thank you so much for having me.
I'm Michelle Poler,
I am the founder of Hello fears,
which is a community made
out of non conformance,
so, people who want more out of life,
and after leading this community
for the last five years,
I launched my first book
called "Hello Fears",
only two weeks ago,
and I already.
- Congratulations.
- Thank you.
So, I've already sold over 4000 books,
which is pretty cool,
taking into account that we're
in the middle of a pandemic.
But I'd love to see this book
take off beyond my followers,
and I've seen how powerful the content is
based on the success
of my speaking career,
and the feedback from my community
has been overwhelmingly positive,
so I believe so much in it,
that I feel I haven't been
able to do justice to it.
So, I think that if I can
get the right influencers
to support this message,
then the impact could be huge,
and I'd love to know,
what would you recommend?
What are some of the
ways to have influencers
interested in our products?
So, maybe it's only a matter of time,
but I don't wanna leave this to chance,
I actually wanna go and grab it.
- Yeah so, I don't know if, you know,
I think a lot of people view,
first of all, congratulations,
that's a lot of books in
a short period of time.
I think a lot of people
want to rely on influencers,
but, you know, influencers
can and do move books,
but I think a lot of time is spent on it,
plus, the reality is,
influencers wanna be compensated.
You know, there's two ways to do it.
There's the transactional way,
and then there's the authentic way.
The authentic way is it
naturally gets its own steam,
one person passes on,
recommends it and away it goes.
You can market that by over
investing in influencers
and paying them to post.
There's a level of transaction
that eliminates the
authenticity of that shout-out.
My belief is that the number
one way to really get books out
is through access and
what I mean by that is,
going to that community
that bought 4000 and say,
"Look, I'm gonna do a
five hour Q&A livestream,
but you have to buy 15 copies of the book,
you have to submit your
receipt from Amazon
that you bought 15 copies,
and then that will be your pass in,
and then you have to give
away those 15 copies,
to friends and family.
Now, what you're doing is,
you're taking your people
that actually care,
that actually value you,
and you're making them part
of the overall team, right,
and you're spreading it
with a more authentic way.
I think that influencer
marketing is one of the best,
you know, ways to market.
However, people are too
ideological about it.
Like, you know, you're
gonna need to either pay
or have it happened authentically.
- Yeah, no, I definitely
don't wanna pay, I want,
I know that if the right
influencers looked at this book,
like, with the right audience,
they will want to share it.
So, it's a matter of.
- So then, it's just a matter
of just sending them the...
You're paying in a different way,
you're sending them the book,
and then you're hoping
that they actually share it.
- But it's hard because,
I think the hardest part right now is that
because we're in a
pandemic and we're home,
people are not at their offices.
If you ask influencers for their address,
they don't wanna give
you their home address,
they just wanna give you their office,
yeah, and they're not there,
so, I've been sending it to.
- I think that's an excuse,
like influencers are
getting unlimited products
sent to their P.O boxes and
offices and having it delivered.
I think that if you called and said,
"I've got $5,000 for you, where
would you like me to send it
if you post and review this?"
Miraculously, their office
is gonna be fucking open.
I think that's an excuse that,
you're making that excuse and
they're making that excuse,
because most people don't want to,
post about things without
naturally feeling it
or being compensated for it.
So, I also think it comes down to
how many influencers have
you asked or reached out to.
- And what about
how hard it is to reach
an influencer nowadays?
For example, if they don't use Instagram,
like so many influencers
are very active and I,
and you know they would look at their DMs,
but some, for example, Brene Brown,
she's not really on Instagram,
so, she's really hard to get
in that way, is there any?
- I mean, look,
here's where audacity takes over, right,
where you need to be careful.
You know, if you want Brene
Brown to shout-out your book,
it shouldn't be as easy as,
"hey, shout-out my book."
I think that you send her
a copy with a nice letter,
to whatever address you can find,
that the letter is your only
prayer of getting her to do it.
Or you DM her or you
hit her up on LinkedIn,
I mean, it's just asking,
but you have so little
leverage in that scenario.
Literally, there's 40,000 people
trying to get to Brene
Brown on a daily basis,
to promote their product for them,
with nothing in return for Brene.
- Definitely, yes.
- And just
even say the sentence.
You know, like, "I would
like you to do this for me,
I have nothing to offer you,
other than I believe this is good,"
but everybody thinks
their baby is the cutest.
Everybody thinks their book is the best.
Everybody thinks their makeup or course,
or meditation thing,
or you know, premium product,
everybody thinks that.
- I know, I know, but I,
well, for me, I've seen the success
because of my speaking career.
- Of course, people have seen the success
on everything that they put out.
Whether you're right or wrong,
the relationship between getting somebody
to give you something of value,
with nothing in return for them,
comes out of a couple places.
You've earned it by creating
a relationship with them
for a long period of time,
you got lucky out of the
goodness of their heart
and they're doing something nice for you
just 'cause they feel it,
or the book is naturally good
and gets recommended from somebody else,
and it finds its way to that person.
But, you know, approaching something with,
"Hey, everybody, you know, like,
I've seen this work 'cause
my speaking career is epic,
and people fucking love it,"
that comes across as tone deaf.
So, it's fucking a million other people.
- Yeah, yeah, it's just,
it's so much work to put into one product,
it launches, it's doing really
good in that period of time,
and then you feel like, that's it,
should I continue pushing
or should I allow time?
- You should definitely keep pushing.
You should always push,
if you want it to be successful.
Like, it's gonna breed without you,
even while you're pushing.
Those things are happening in parallel,
they're not individually situations.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
It just feels a little bit
like postpartum depression,
you know, when you push
the baby out and then.
- Well, because you know that,
obviously, that's a different
scenario altogether but
what I see with a lot of
authors is their expectations.
People create this narrative in their mind
that this book is gonna come out,
and it's going to become a viral sensation
and they're gonna be on "Today's Show"
and every influencer is gonna
be posting a copy of it,
and their fame is gonna explode
and they're gonna start
making 10 times more speaking,
and they create all these scenarios
without realizing the
world's got a million things
to look at besides their book.
- Yeah, I think that's the hardest part,
like the expectations, right,
of what we put into it.
- I think so too.
I think that, listen, it requires,
micro speed and macro patience.
On a day to day basis,
you have to keep pushing,
pushing, pushing on.
In the real game, I still get to,
People tweet me, this weekend
that they've found "Crush
It" and they love it,
I wrote that book 12 years ago.
- Yeah, I love that book (laughs).
Well, thank you so much for writing it.
- You're welcome, you're welcome.
Look, I think that you need
to really think about it,
what's in it for the other person?
- Yeah, yeah.
- That's the key.
- Mm hmm.
- You know, what's in
it for the other person?
Not what's in it for you.
Because when people come
from what's in it for them,
they tend to fall short of
what they're looking for.
- Mm hmm, and I'm not even,
honestly, looking for me,
even though, of course,
this can take my career to the next level,
but I just know so many people
should be reading this book,
mostly now, it's about facing your fears
and becoming who you're
meant to be and it's,
this is the right time
to be talking about fear.
- You need to be reaching
out to every podcast
every platform you can
and getting out there
and talking about it,
whether that is a podcast
that has 200 listeners
or whether it has 3000 listeners,
you need to be in constant
motion, constant promotion
and figure it out.
- Yeah, definitely.
Thank you, Gary.
- Awesome, good luck,
take care, have a nice day.
(slurps)
Yeah, that's that, let's keep it going.
You're on mute Bella.
- Oh, shit, hi?
- You're good, how are you?
- Hi?
- How are you?
- I'm good, hi, thank you.
- Sure.
- So, wow, this is crazy.
I've been trying to meet
you for like four years,
but...
- (chuckles) Here we are.
- Nice to meet you.
- I'm so nervous.
- Where are you from?
- I'm from New York.
- Awesome.
- Yeah.
So, my question is,
like, how do I stop self doubting myself
because you're really big on that
and not caring about
what others say, because,
can I just give you,
like, a little backdrop?
- Yeah, please.
- Okay.
So, just to make a long story short,
I was pregnant as 16 years old,
I became a mother, I got emancipated,
did whatever I had do, worked my ass off,
put myself through school,
and a lot of my family's old school,
and they disowned me.
I'm sure you know.
- Yeah, I get it.
- So,
and
I had a great career,
but I was still in that
relationship with that person
because I didn't wanna
hear my family being like,
"Oh, we told you so or whatever",
'cause they were all, they're all yanters.
(Gary laughs)
They all do this.
They all do this shit.
- Of course, yap.
- So,
it was a really bad relationship,
like really bad, bad, abusive.
If I knew better, I would have done better
but I wanna use my experience
to help, like, other women and even men,
'cause men get abused too,
females could pull some shit on some men.
So, I mean, you know,
kids and stuff like that.
So, I was working in the
emergency medical field,
I was working in-house
and I was working on EMS,
and the last time my
children's father assaulted me,
he basically left me for dead
and I was working, I
thought everything was fine,
just bruised up or whatever
and I ended up having a
grand mal seizure on shift.
So, I'm right there, like my whole career,
just fucking gone, done.
Because how can I take care of anybody?
You know what I mean?
The seizures weren't under control.
So, they found out
that it was blunt force trauma
to the head, what have you,
and I just felt so mad,
like this crazy madness,
that turned into depression,
that turned into everything else.
So, to make a long story short,
I had even started like,
I saw you in 2017,
you are on like a inspirational
motivational video
with Tom Bilyeu and Tony Robbins, them,
and I used to watch this video every day,
every day, every day,
because I was so depressed
and it really did help,
like, save my life,
so, I thank you for that.
So, with my time off of,
you know, I have two, I have
a 15 year old, an 11 year old.
I'm out of work, I didn't,
I wasn't able to refresh
like all my stuff and,
so, I took the time I
was like, you know what,
let me try this life coaching thing.
This was like, a couple years ago,
but I wanted to do, like,
a life course, so anyways,
sorry if I'm talking too fast (mumbles).
- No, no, no, go ahead, do your thing.
- Okay.
So, I had started, like,
life coaching course for
transformational solution focused,
but I'm like, "Damn Bella,
like how are you gonna do that
when you're not there?"
So, I had to like start healing myself.
But I've always, with
my past line of work,
it was something in me,
even though, whatever
was going on at home,
when I went to work.
- You turned on.
- Man,
it was like,
everything, nothing matters.
- That was your escape, right?
Like, you think about a
lot of athletes talk about,
with all this shit going on,
but when I was on the
court, I was able to zone in
and by the way, I'm
the same way with work.
So, you were able to,
that was like your escape.
- That was my escape but
it was also so rewarding,
like, I always had like
Outstanding Service Awards
and stuff like, I want to be on it.
- It was your zone
- In it, you know,
I worked behavior, how?
I branched off into so many things,
and then, it was just
like taken like that.
So after, I had to go see
somebody for depression
and I know like a lot of
people watching this but,
it's like my first time really, like.
- Talking about it.
- Telling somebody I don't
know like that.
I did make a couple videos on YouTube,
'cause I just wanted to use
my voice to get it out there
because even if there's
a 16 year old girl,
right this minute, that just
found out she's pregnant
and her mother screaming, you
know, "Get out the house",
maybe it'll help her,
you know what I mean?
To know not to go until you're
11 years later with this
dude, two kids later,
and then, you know what I mean?
Like everything was just gone.
- Of course, I now what you mean.
One of the things I
talk about in a far less
crazy scenarios, far
less intense scenario,
is people don't fire people
because they don't wanna be wrong
in front of everybody else's eyes.
You stayed in this
really terrible situation
'cause you didn't want
everybody's opinions
to be right over you,
when they were judging
you at such a young age.
People live their lives based
on other people's opinions.
This is like so much of what
my framework is to talk about
because I don't want that to be the case
'cause you probably stayed in
that, god awful relationship
for seven years, eight
years, nine years too long,
because you didn't want
your mom and grandma
and aunt and cousins to be right.
- But then I'm like, why do I even care?
Because, I feel like
my mom has put me down since I was young.
You know what I mean?
Just because you fed me,
and whatever, I was born
into, like, bad blood.
It's just what it is.
- Let's talk about bad blood.
You were born into a situation where,
based on what you're saying,
your mom was in a bad place,
and so, misery loves company,
like, misery loves company,
doesn't exclude family,
it often puts family in the frontlines.
- Right, exactly.
- I mean, that framework,
probably, led to a lot
of your decision making
in your early teen years.
- Yeah, 'cause I was trying to get out,
like, get out of, you know what I mean?
- Yes I do.
- I guess my question is,
so yeah, so I was like, okay, you know,
let me try public speaking,
I had went to college in Connecticut
and spoke about sexual
assault and stuff like that,
on "Take Back The Night",
and I had went to high school
and talk to a few upperclassmen.
But I don't know why I'm,
like, so nervous right now,
'cause it's you.
- Don't be, don't be.
(laughs)
- But, I wanna, you know,
I'm not in a situation right now
where I can go and open up
shelters and stuff like that,
but that's what I wanna do.
I'm 40 years old, you know what I mean?
I'm 40.
- You got tons of time.
- I feel like I missed so much time,
staying stuck, depressed and
all fucked up in my head.
Sorry, I curse a lot.
- No,
who are you talking to?
- Yeah, it's you.
- You know, but listen,
I think on the flip side,
you have an ungodly amount
of time in front of you.
- Yeah.
- I mean, you've 50, 60
years in front of you.
So, the first thing you have to do is...
- I'm not gonna love
to be no 100 years old.
- Why not Bella?
- I don't know.
You know, I gotta think more positive.
I really need to think more
positive because it's like,
I'm trying to help other women,
like, I wanna go to a shelter
and I was just thinking
about this other day
after watching your show.
And even like pro bono be like,
"Listen, if there's anybody here
that doesn't have insurance,"
or whatever, sometimes, you know,
people don't wanna talk to counselors,
and they don't wanna talk about
what's going on in the house because,
DCF or CPS or
the woman's afraid
a man's gonna beat her
ass when he finds out.
I've been there.
- That's right, it's fear.
Of course, you lived it.
- You know what I'm saying?
- Which is why your voice is important,
because you come from
a place of credibility.
- But I just don't know where to start,
because I don't know how to.
- Let me help you.
The place to start is the internet.
- I know, I just, I was,
it took me forever to just
make that video on like,
the first time he assaulted me,
and then I thought like.
- Of course.
It wasn't about the video,
it was about what you were saying.
I mean, that's a deep pain and
a very secretive structure.
It didn't take you forever,
because you don't know how to make a video
or YouTube is scary, it's what
you were saying was scary.
- Yeah, yeah, I didn't know...
- You were in a framework for a decade
of a fear cocoon that,
I mean, you went from one scary place
to another scary place.
This is your time to finally,
like, really breathe.
- Like I want to, you know what I mean,
but it's like, how do I
network to get out there to,
I don't,
I feel like shit,
charging for life coaching.
- I understand.
- You know what I mean?
And then it's diluted fucking field
because you have and forgive me,
but you have 17, 18 year olds taking a
over the weekend class
and boom, "hey, I know,
listen, as I tell you, I've
been through some shit,"
you know, that's good
for them to learn but,
it was like, I'm like, damn,
there's so many life coaches,
I don't even know what the fuck to do.
So, I kinda fell back, where I was like,
you know what, I don't know,
maybe I'll just go back
into the emergency field,
but I'm worn out from that field,
and then, being in the
relationship I was in.
I started very young, like I said,
when I have two children
here, I'm a single mother,
like I'm just.
- Listen Bella,
you're 40 going on 90,
who's gonna live to 90.
So, you've got a lot of like,
I have a lot of compassion
for where you're coming from.
This all makes a ton of sense to me.
Everything feels really true and facts.
I think, a couple things.
One, you can't worry about how many other
life coaches there are,
'cause that has nothing to do with you.
That will play out.
Like, you know, like, you know,
the reality is...
- That's the self doubt in me.
- I know it is, that's
why I'm bringing it up.
Like, that's just, that's not gonna,
you're gonna have to keep...
The fact that you're starting
to put these things out,
the fact that you recognize those truths,
you're already halfway home.
You have to understand,
a decade ago, you were still in that,
five years ago, you're in that cocoon,
you're not even in this place,
you're in such a great place right now.
You need to build on top of this.
But the only way you're gonna do it,
it's similar to working out,
you have to put in the reps.
You have to make the content,
you can't go and you know,
you're not gonna go.
You're not building a clinic yet.
You know, right now everything's closed.
So you're not going much to many places,
but what you can do
is attack the foundation
of putting out content
and sharing your mind.
- Like, I wanna write a book.
- That's fine, but start
with putting out content.
- Okay, and I just started to.
- You have to do it often a
lot and for a period of time,
and then you can build on that.
You know, like, listen, you
I think of life like poker,
even though I'm not a poker player,
but I do understand what this part is.
Some people are handed two aces in their,
when they get the first
two cards in poker,
and they lose.
- Right.
- They miss play that hand.
- Other people get a three and
a seven offsuit, a shit hand,
but they literally figure
out how to win that hand.
- Right.
- You know clearly
taking you for your word
and like, the story you're telling.
Like, your foundation was maybe,
a three and a seven offsuit, a tough hand.
However, the reality is,
you can win that hand,
and right now, you're at the part where
you're starting to
really have a foundation
to give yourself a chance.
What you're gonna need to
do more than anything else,
is not think about all
the time you wasted,
you have to think about
all the time you have.
Because if you get yourself
caught up in all the time
you quote unquote wasted,
you're gonna become impatient,
and you're gonna do dumb shit,
'cause you're gonna try to
make it happen too fast.
- Right.
No, I definitely understand that
because that's how I was like, in 2017.
Like I wasn't healed, I was...
(dog barks)
I'm sorry.
- No worries.
(dog barks)
No worry about the dog.
Dog is having fun.
(dog barks)
(stutters)
They're living.
- Can somebody get this, Marley Please.
- Marley keep barking.
Marley keep barking, Bella,
Marley barking isn't good isn't an issue,
Marley barking is a
good thing, keep going.
- So.
Shit, he just like messed up
my whole fucking thinking.
- Your whole thinking
is a very simple game,
I can restart it for you over and over.
(laughs)
You had a tough framework and now you want
and you've got all this, kind
of, resentment and worries
and you were in this cloud
and you're starting the process now
to actually get out of it,
and the number one
thing, by a country mile,
that you have to work on,
is developing patience in
the face of a framework
that doesn't look like
patience is the answer,
because you've been wasting so much time.
Yet patience is the biggest
thing you have to lean into,
and what that will then do,
is allow you to put out
content on a daily basis.
Not overthink it, not hope
that every piece of content
is gonna be your viral piece of content,
and you need to just speak your truth.
When you were speaking your truth in here,
the comments were like, in love with that,
because it's authentic, it's real,
and it's something people
can associate with.
You've gotta put out a lot more of that.
- There's much, much
more to put out of it.
I just want to ask...
- I'm sure
you've unlimited stories.
- But the thing is that the person that
well, he had gotten involved
in a high profile thing
that maybe after that, when we talk,
I can talk to you and tell you.
- Okay.
- 'Cause it's,
you know who he is and it.
- 'Cause the world knows who
he is, or I know who he is?
- Everybody knows and it's kinda like,
that's why i stalled because
I got depressed and I was like,
"Oh now, this bitch goes
and does something with a famous person."
So, basically he was with a famous person,
and you go and murder somebody and
I'm like, what the fuck?
I wasn't gonna put him on blast anyways,
but I kinda felt like,
Damn!
Like, you know why.
- Listen,
this is clearly a deep
fucked up situation, right?
The reality is.
- Right, but I started to heal
I'm trying.
- You're clearly in that place.
(Bella laughs)
Like I didn't think.
But really, you're clearly in that place.
You just need to,
look, that's a lot of baggage.
- I can't believe that I
just said that, oh, my God.
- You know, it's a lot of baggage,
but you're clearly building
on the next chapter and you
need to keep building on it.
You need to put stuff out,
Bella, you need to put stuff out.
You know?
- Yeah.
- You gotta get it out of your system,
both publicly and privately,
like, that is the framework.
- I did the private part.
I did get therapy and stuff,
I had to, you know, I.
- You may need to do that
forever and that's okay,
that's a strength, not a weakness.
- I still see a therapist.
- That's great,
I'm proud of you.
- Thank you, thank you.
- That's what you should be doing.
- That's why I was so
nervous to come on here,
because I'm like, I, you
know, obviously, like,
close people to me know, and stuff.
But what also happened at
that time when I wanted to,
I had a whole bunch of shit set up, but,
and please, anybody watching
this, don't get me wrong.
But when somebody goes and
starts a movement of me too,
you can't just
go back 60 years and start talking about
everybody that did this, this, this, this.
So, it, kind of, people were
really getting funny with that,
and I was like,
I never used that, me too,
thing, you know what I mean?
So,
I respect it wholly, I respect it,
but what I'm trying to say is, sometimes,
real shit gets watered
down, when people...
- Of course
- Okay.
- But other women's truths
don't need to impact you.
Do you know what I mean?
- Right, right, right,
but I wanna unite with
them, like, I wanna.
- But unite with people that
wanna unite on your terms
in your framework, do you understand?
Like.
- Right.
- Listen, for example, a
lot of people right now
are just going crazy and are like,
yo, Bella, you have to start a podcast.
- Oh my God!
- Like, listen,
you've got also all sorts
of stuff inside of you.
Clearly a lot of stories, a lot of stuff.
The more you get it out in public,
the more strength you're gonna have.
You know, that whole story
and obviously you've been watching like,
you referenced it already,
the whole thought of like
helping one 16 year old girl,
that's real shit.
- One person, that would mean the world.
One person.
- Imagine when you were
16, like you turned on MTV,
and somebody like you
said something that changed your mindset,
your whole life would be different.
- I'm telling you, because
I had a dance career,
I like, danced all my life,
that's why my family
was so upset with, like,
they were just shitty to
me with it, but you know.
- It sounds like your mom was
shitty before it even started.
Like, it was a lot there,
but the reality is,
the only thing that heals
is exposing shadows,
- Absolutely.
- And you come from, you know,
listen, I come from this framework too,
which is like, you keep shit private.
You don't snitch, you don't (mumbles),
all that shit like,
it's very obvious, I get it,
but the reality is that,
especially if shits out already,
well, then you're just,
then you're healing yourself.
That's not snitching,
that's you healing yourself.
- I never would, like I said,
I never put his name out there,
I never did anything like
that because I'm like,
no, I'm not gonna,
it's embarrassing and he's
a bum, like what the fuck?
You know?
- You were 16, Bella.
- Yeah.
- It's not embarrassing.
- I was 16 and,
I wish that I knew this stuff that I know.
- You were 16, it's not embarrassing.
Every fucking person in the comments
and watching this right
now, did dumb shit at 16.
- Yeah, and they're all
amazing, like, I got on earlier
in the very beginning,
like, I woke up at four this morning
because I was freaking out, and
they're just so supportive.
Like, you have the best
chat, you know why?
'Cause when we're in there,
we support each other.
When somebody comes in
and starts like talking
shit or spamming, we don't,
you know, we're not assholes
to them, we just kinda.
- We don't play (laughs).
- Like, get the fuck out here (laughs).
- Bella, keep telling.
- But thanks,
I appreciate you.
- Put out content,
keep telling your story.
- Okay.
- All right?
- Okay, do I have to
and I've DMed for like months,
every day there were chances.
I have.
- I'm glad you made.
- So, thank you so much.
- You're welcome, have a good day.
- You too, bye.
- All right, bye, bye.
Man, a lot of stuff.
I hope that helps put people
in perspective, right?
Like, there's just so
many different things
people deal with and like,
I always tell people,
you've got something heavy,
somebody's got something heavier,
and just like, I hope Bella
helped you this morning,
just put things in perspective.
Some people really have some heavy shit.
Let's keep it going.
- What is up GaryVee?
- What's up, Tana, how are you?
(laughs)
- I'm good.
- Putting in the work.
- This is my tea time right here.
- I love that.
How are things?
- I have a question.
Things have been good,
I feel like I'm stuck.
With everything going on, it's just,
I feel like I'm not really
creative with content right now,
and so, I wanted to ask you,
how do we get more creative?
What would you be doing
with your extra time?
Would you be just trying
to get content out?
Would you be trying to
learn something new?
Like, I've always been
interested in day trading,
so I'm like, should I just
do a little bit of both?
Does that take focus from
my online training business?
- Well, I think that you're...
- I am wasting my life.
- No worries, no worries.
Well, I think Tana, I think clearly,
if you're asking the question,
you do wanna get distracted
from your core thing,
and I think both options
that you threw out,
content and learning day
trading, both makes sense,
and I think all three,
being in play is a great idea.
Like, I don't know, are you putting,
"hey, don't spread yourself
thin on a pedestal,"
like, do you think it's important to,
like, do you subscribe to the focus of
focus on one thing, because for me,
and I've said it so often
over these two months,
focusing on many things is my
strength, it's what I like.
- Yeah, 'cause that's
always my biggest fear
is like, I've done online
trading for almost 10 years.
So, a lot of it is repetitive
and I feel like I need something exciting
and new and day trading is like.
- You clearly do, you clearly do.
Like, if you're looking for affirmation,
or confirmation that your
intuitions right here,
like I'll give it to you.
Your vibes are very
clear to me that you do,
like you just need to do it, you know,
because you need to see it through.
Just to see if you like it.
Like the testing of it is so important.
- Okay, yeah, of course.
Well, I'll do that,
and then, how have you been able to like,
stay creative with content
creation during this time?
- By being happy.
(laughs)
- Oh, man, okay, I mean.
- You know what I mean?
Like, if you're not in
a good place mentally,
then it's already difficult to go there.
If you're not in a great
quote unquote place,
then it's really hard for you to give.
When you're in a place
where you need something,
it's hard for you to be
the one that's giving.
For me, I don't need anything,
because all this stuff I've
been talking about for a decade
plays out in times like this,
because the reality is that,
if you keep life simple,
all of a sudden, it's just
really really, really easy
to be in a good spot.
- Yeah.
Yeah, 'cause I am going
through a lot, like,
whole custody battle,
and then everything got put on lockdown,
and it's like, I already work from home.
So the only places I
ever went was like gym,
tanning, salon and grocery store.
(laughs)
Now, it's like, you can't do any of that.
And, like, I just workout at
home, hang out with my baby,
and like, that's really it.
So I'm like, I've been trying to meditate,
doing more journaling,
just like tap in and really figure out,
what do you wanna talk about?
And since I've been battling a lot with?
- Good, since you've
been battling a lot with?
- Oh, well, yeah, I was just saying like,
I've been battling a lot with eating bad.
So, I've been doing fellowship Fridays,
like, you know, telling everyone like,
"yeah, I keep telling myself
I'm gonna do better with eating
but like, haven't been able
to do my intermittent fasting
or stay away from ice cream or wine."
And so, it's like I've been
trying just be authentic.
- I think that's super powerful.
I think beating yourself up like,
I've gained seven or eight
pounds during this time,
and I feel great about it because
I've focused on muscle gain,
and I know that in a couple months
when I'm back to a routine
where there's not food
around the house all day,
that I'll be able to get my shit together.
I don't think you need to beat yourself up
for a two to four month period
where we had a global pandemic,
once in a, kind of,
generation thing happened.
This is not the time to be
over devastated about your macros.
- Yeah, okay.
Well, that's good.
- It's about judgment, right?
- Yeah, it is.
- It's about not judging yourself.
It's like, just really, really, really
getting to that place, you know?
- Yeah, no, and that's
so true, so thank you.
- You're welcome.
(both speaking)
I think the one thing that
might be able to help you,
I would highly recommend
going into an Instagram Live
and just talking to people.
Bring people on, answer their question.
I find a lot of times creativity
comes from the community,
and so I think that,
I think that is gonna really
be, maybe, a trigger for you.
- Okay, (mumbles).
- Try that.
- And I'm trying about that last night.
So, awesome.
- Try that.
- Awesome, good luck.
- I will.
- All right, take care.
- Thank you, I appreciate.
- Got it.
All right, let's keep it going.
I like the workout Q&A.
- Gary, how's the going?
- It's going well, brother, how are you?
- I'm good, friend, I'm good.
I just wanted to start off
by saying massive thank you,
to all the help you've given me,
like, you've helped me grow so much.
I've only been watching
your stuff for a few months,
and honestly, you've
changed my life completely.
- How did you find it, Scott?
- So, I actually found it on YouTube.
I just saw your stuff,
I saw one of the videos.
It was about like Instagram DM,
and I just, I got hooked, and
I start watching your videos,
and the thing about me is,
I'm a very logical thinker,
and so, I had to, kind of,
watch a lot of your stuff,
and then take a while to digest it,
and make sense of it myself
and then go off and apply it.
And after that, I've been applying it,
you know, I've seen some success.
It's been great, so, thanks so much man.
- What can I help you with?
- My question is, I know, you're
very big on producing like,
at least like eight to 15
pieces of content in a day,
and so, I'm a music artist,
and also a club promoter,
and this is something that
I'm really struggling with.
I'm really not too sure
how to hitting that number,
I'm only doing what sort of four.
- The number, Scott, the
number is theoretical.
I wish you could put out
100 piece of content a day,
and by the way, the more
platforms you're on,
the easier it is to put out content.
And when you're on Twitter,
where that content may
be five or six thoughts
that you just write out in written form,
and not a fucking YouTube vlog,
all of a sudden, that number
becomes more obtainable.
The numbers are arbitrary,
I've thrown out eight, 15,
four a day, 30, 100, 64.
Those are just numbers that
are, kind of, theoretical.
What I'm trying to do is
get people to get into a
comfort zone of understanding
the more you're able to
actually create and produce,
the more likely something will happen.
Something happens when
you put something out.
You know, like, you know.
- Yeah.
- I always think this all the time.
The amount of artists, music
artists that were meant,
or could have been one hit
wonders or had a real career,
but they cut one song out of their album,
when they put out the first ever album,
and that was the song that
was destined to be a top hit,
and then it never happened.
Well, that sucks, but with the internet,
that doesn't need to happen.
Like, you know, everything
should be put out.
- Right, right.
And I know like you always
talk about context as well,
is that where that
comes into play as well.
- Correct, because the
way to win on platforms
is understanding how TikTok
works differently than LinkedIn,
that works differently than Twitter.
So, the context of the
platform a lot of times
is going to be the variable of success.
It's why we say watch
what I do, not what I say,
like, why am I trying so many
different formats on Instagram
on TikTok, on Twitter,
like, why am I doing that?
I'm not doing that for my health,
it's because I'm testing,
trying different things,
doing different things,
and those things lead to observations.
My latest content pillar on Instagram
is the sketched, kind of,
pictures of me with quotes,
and they're outperforming the
ones that look like tweets.
You know, if I didn't think of to do that,
which came from an insight
that I got from a wine text ad,
that mean, Dwayne on my team created.
So like, if you're not
constantly in motion and trying,
you're not gonna find
the thing that's gonna
be your breakthrough,
if you keep doing the same shit.
People hit me up all
the time, they're like
"Gary, I've put out 1000 piece
of content like you said,
it's not working,"
and then I go look at their Instagram,
it's all the same kind of content.
I'm like, the market
told you a long time ago
that they don't like that.
- Yeah.
Okay, okay, I see.
What platforms would you
would you recommend most?
- All of them, but for an artist,
you know, TikTok, Instagram, YouTube,
Snapchat, like, you know,
Twitter, they're all in play.
- I see, and is it kind of
like Sony did to "Daily Vee",
and that was literally just
like a whole day of you,
is it kinda of that
larger, sort of, split up
into different parts
across multiple platforms?
- I mean, that worked for me,
because after seven years
of doing content myself,
I was able to afford hiring somebody
and then once you hire somebody
to film everything you're doing,
and you're a kind of person like me,
that's busy every fucking
minute, for 15 hours a day,
that led to a lot of content.
That's not the reality
for a lot of people.
- Yeah.
- But you know,
filming you promoting
a club or doing a show
from coast to coast, like,
that's kinda interesting shit.
So, maybe and by the way, I
hired somebody and paid them,
but a lot of people would do that for free
because they just wanna
be close to that action.
When you're in music or
you're in club promoting,
that's fun life and there's
a lot of people with a camera
that are willing to
fuckin' do it for free,
because they can never get
that close to that coolness
and so, there's just a
lot of ways to attack it.
- I see, I see.
Okay, well thank you so much, Gary,
that's really helped a lot.
- You're welcome mate.
Listen, don't overthink, make.
- Okay.
Got it.
- You being that logical,
you're gonna out think yourself
and in that thinking.
- Yeah, I think a lot.
- What's the time to make?
Reverse it, realize you'll
have better thoughts
if you learn from what's
working and not working.
I think a lot.
I just make and then
consume and then think.
I don't have the audacity or ego
to think I'm gonna figure it
out myself before I put it out.
I put it out and then
learn from the reaction.
That's how I think, that's the reverse,
and I think you need to consider that.
- Right, so, you're listening more.
- You're listening and what
that takes is humility.
- Yeah, sure.
Okay, thank you so much,
Gary, thanks so much.
- You have to have the self
confidence to not get the likes.
- Yeah.
Awesome, thanks for that, mate, thank you.
- You're welcome, mate, take care.
- Take easy.
- All right, let's keep it going.
- Gary, what's up?
- What's good, bro, what's your name?
- How's it going, Jake.
- Jake, real pleasure.
- Definitely, real pleasure.
I got the mug life going on this morning.
- I love that bro, is that a Mario?
- It is, it's a Super
Mario mug, heck yeah.
Hashtag muglife.
- I saw the quick stones
and I fucking new it.
(laughs)
- Awesome.
So, I am Jake, I have a YouTube channel,
and we do comedy sketches
and stuff like that.
My biggest question
to, kind of, piggyback
off of Scott's question,
a lot of what I've been doing recently
is just, kind of, doing that
putting out as much as I
can, good quality content,
what I wanna do, what I know
my audience is gonna like,
it's helped grow my TikTok.
It's helped grow the YouTube a little bit.
I've had the channel for seven years
and I've seen the most
growth in the past six months
than I've seen ever.
It's not much.
- You feel like that's coming
from TikTok over to YouTube?
- I think, like, it's coming
from everywhere, yeah,
from constantly posting
on Facebook, Twitter.
A lot of my analytics,
I've been kind of working
on the back end a little bit
not obsessing over it,
but a lot of the tips and tricks I'm doing
are kinda helping me get in search
and on the front page and whatnot,
a couple times here and there.
But my biggest thing is like,
if I'm gonna be doing
collaborations with people over time
'cause I wanna start reaching out
and start to, kind of, network that,
it's crazy, I'm already
seeing like subscribers,
that's weird.
(laughs)
So, doing that and
collaborating with people
and not overwhelming myself,
is like the biggest thing for me.
'Cause I tend to, like,
throw everything at the wall,
and then, you know, you get
stuck in that reaction of
okay, well, this isn't
working, this isn't working.
You know, I've been getting
better at just kinda pushing on.
So I guess.
- Something not working is good.
- Definitely.
Let's see, that's why I ...
- Let's say here, Jake,
like, if you don't have the
expectation that this collab
or this execution or this tactic,
it's gonna change everything,
and you just like the fact
that you're trying new shit.
- Yeah.
- You know, like, to me,
that's the whole framework.
Like for me, as I start
doing this, I'm like,
okay, right, that's why shit works for me.
I have no expectations.
- Right.
- I get excited to learn.
- Yeah, yeah.
- And then if something
works, it's like gravy,
but I'm not hurt by the waste of time.
I think it's why I love garage selling.
- Yeah.
- I can spend like five hours
and if I don't find anything,
it was the game that I liked,
not the fact that, fuck,
I didn't find like,
a huge box of Super Nintendo games.
You know what I mean?
- Yeah, I used to work in a thrift store
and I would do a lot of the
antiquing cool junk stuff,
shout-out to the Bridge
Teen Center in Orland.
(laughs)
It was literally like
one of my favorite jobs
and it was like just seeing all that stuff
kind of, got me inspired to start,
looking into that and
collecting like vintage stuff.
and you know, that's when
I found you on YouTube,
and then I found out my dad's
followed you for 10 plus years,
I'm like, oh my god.
Like, that's crazy,
and I'm like, I gotta start
getting into this guy,
and it was just when I started
listening to that advice,
it started working
and it just seems the more that
I'm reaching out with people
and doing that, it's where
that overwhelming like,
I'm doing too much, yo.
- No, you're not doing too much,
you're doing too little.
- All right, okay, good to hear.
- I'm being serious.
- Yeah.
- You're not doing too much,
you're doing too little.
- This is like all I have, I literally,
I dropped out of college,
I worked my job into retail management
and I'm never going back.
Like that's been my motto, so.
- So, the answer is
you're doing too little.
- Right.
- What you're doing is
you're doing too little,
and you're judging yourself too much.
- Right, yeah.
I posted a thing on Reddit
yesterday or like two days ago.
I took your advice, I just
screenshotted some tweets
that are mine that were motivational,
that were like, hey,
pump up, like, you know,
like, fuck the noise, who
cares what everybody else says,
do what you wanna do that makes you happy,
and like within two nights,
each of them gets like 100 likes
100 upvotes each, it's
like, it's slowly starting,
I'm seeing a couple
Twitter followers come in.
- Reddit has an amazing community.
- I would have never thought,
I saw that old platform, that's it.
(laughs)
- It's you're doing too little
and you're judging too much,
is the mantra to so many people.
- Right.
- Like, like.
- I'm ever doing it a million times.
- But in the way I'm saying
it now, it even hits for me,
like, I haven't said exactly like that.
Like I haven't said
you're doing too little,
I macro said it in the specific,
no, like if you have a dream
to stand on your own two feet
and fucking live this life
based on what you wanna do,
you're never doing enough,
it's that you're never doing enough,
but your mind has to tell you
that you're not beating yourself
up for not doing enough.
It's okay, like, it's about
self love and heavy execution.
- Okay.
- You're not stretched thin, you wouldn't,
like, everybody's worried like,
"oh damn, I just focused on one platform,"
but they all intertwine.
Thing right learn on TikTok
are gonna help you on YouTube.
Something you do on YouTube
comments helps you on Twitter.
It's more complex than that.
And so, it's about the lack of judgment
and not being crippled by having
too many things in the air.
- Okay, see 'cause that's
the biggest thing for me
is like I look at it way too,
I think maybe way too.
- Literal.
- Yeah, yeah.
And I'm like okay, if I'm
spending on all this ideas,
I have to execute, you
know, and it's just.
- Yeah, even the way you set up,
like I'm looking at my
analytics, but not too much,
bro, I've been like.
(mumbles)
Exactly, bro, you're
not gonna believe this.
12 years, I don't think I've
spent 20 minutes on analytics.
I have no fucking idea.
- Right, right.
- But wait,
but I could be better.
Knowing that makes me know
that I don't have as much
juice on YouTube as I could,
'cause that's a very analytical game.
I don't give a fuck.
- Well, a lot of the people
I'm following said it.
Exactly, exactly.
They're saying if you're
gonna be worried about that,
you're worrying too much about
what people that aren't
following you want.
- 100%, you have to create.
- Yeah.
That's what I wanna do.
I wanna inspire people
to create and love so.
- I appreciate it, bro.
- Definitely, peace out.
- Take care, stay well.
Bye, bye.
- Bye.
- Big shout-out to the comments.
Dog hustle, what is good?
Behind The Lens, great to see you.
Zack Drew, good to see you.
Lucassi, good to see you.
Dusty Buck44, what's good.
The Sony Vega, great to have you here,
Jarrod, thank you for being here.
Josh Andrews, I appreciate you.
Really, really glad you're here.
Crazy Caleb, what's good?
Janine Barnard, hi, hi. Hi.
Alright, let's keep going.
- GaryVee.
- Trav, getting in that H2O?
- Yeah, sure, a gallon a day, man.
Listen, so (mumbles).
- The wrestling ship
behind you is incredible.
- What's that?
- The wrestling ship behind is insane.
- Bro, I painted that
mural, I knew you'd like it.
- Holy fuck, dude, that's amazing.
- Thank you, bro.
So, I know I have limited time
but I just want to thank you
so much for this in advance,
just everything you're gonna say
and I appreciate you so much.
So, a really quick back story
so my question makes sense.
So, I'm a creative,
I've been painting since
I was three years old,
I do murals, video, graphic design,
I have a portrait website
that I sell my prints,
and I've been a barber
full time for 15 years,
which I decided to quit this week.
- Wow!
- So,
my wife is also an artist
and we painted murals on
every wall in our house,
like, I'm in my home office right now.
And so, I've been watching
you since about 2014 ish.
I love your content because I
was born and raised in Jersey,
I was the kid in the neighborhood
with a lemonade stand
selling video games.
I had a booming Bootleg CD business.
High school, I was killing it,
go to Chinatown, get all the
stuff before it comes out.
So then 2003, I moved
to Florida for college
'cause I had no clue what
I was doing with my life.
- What part of Jersey did you grow up in?
- I was at Passaic County?
- Love it, what town?
- West Milford, well, yeah, and then.
So, I started barbering
in the hallways in college
to make money as a college kid.
So, I've got a lot of clientele
and I opened up my own
barber shop on the campus
while having my own
custom T-shirt business
with, like, my artwork on it,
and then I started making
YouTube videos in 2009,
and this is where my question comes in.
I started doing that for fun,
well, with my friend at the time,
and I taught myself how to film and edit
and he would rap about 90s cartoons,
and I would paint
whatever he rapped about.
So we had over 150 videos on YouTube,
we started getting some traction.
I had, I would do like five foot paintings
for huge YouTubers,
of their favorite cartoons
or whatever they're into.
I'd try and build relationships
and I'd spend like $200 for shipping
and send it to them as a
surprise to their P.O box,
and they would open it on camera in awe
and shout me out to their
millions of subscribers
and my inbox would explode.
I'd get, you know, more subscribers
and it still works today because
like a couple months ago,
I did a drawing of Ric Flair,
and he ripped it off my Instagram,
posted it on all his social
medias and start you know,
and shouted me out.
So I was like, whoo, you
know what I'm saying?
(laughs)
So, we got up to 44,000 subscribers,
we got millions of views on the channel,
and then brands started reaching out.
So I was on "The Tonight
Show" with Jay Leno,
I worked with Ford, Jolly Rancher,
met Rob Dyrdek and a bunch of celebrities,
and my goal was always
to have a show on MTV.
So, eventually MTV reached out
to do a reality show about my artwork.
I quit barbering, the
day I got the phone call.
We film for three months, they edited it,
and then they shelved the show.
And I became good friends
with my cameraman,
and he said there wasn't enough drama,
'cause I'm a clean cut
guy, so they didn't air it.
And let me.
And I let my youtube
channel go at that time,
'cause I was too busy
filming the MTV show,
and I just hit rock bottom
when MTV didn't work out,
'cause that was my ultimate goal.
and I felt like a failure.
Looking back, I don't know
why I let that break me
'cause MTV is trash anyway.
and it's just like, at that
time I felt like an idiot,
so I deleted all my social media
and disappeared from the internet.
- Wow.
- I was young, dumb and
embarrassed, so like.
- When was this?
- So, this was,
the show was supposed to air in 2014.
- Okay, keep going.
- So, but at the same time,
I also realized that I didn't
wanna pursue being famous.
It wasn't ever truly fulfilling for me,
and when you hang out with celebrities
and people think you made it,
like, it doesn't create
true lasting happiness,
so I got a good taste
of the Hollywood life
without truly being famous.
So I went back to barbering,
and started in art business
on the side doing portraits,
and I sell prints.
I'm not selling this
because I feel weird
selling pictures of you.
(laughs)
Because now I know you,
and I just would never do
that without your permission.
But um.
- You can sell it.
- Man, that's awesome, thanks.
- Approved.
- You are the man.
So.
But,
yeah, so I started barbering again,
I started a wood sign business
and we started making
custom arcade machines.
I bought like $40,000 worth of equipment.
Once it started picking
up, the shop burnt down.
A freak accident,
literally burned to the ground
and I never rebuilt it 'cause I just said
you know what, heck with it,
let me get back into video
because that itch never went away.
So, recently I said enough is enough,
I'm quitting my job, I'm gonna die,
I need to live my life and
I wanna do video full time.
So, I dumped all my savings
into a bunch of new gear
and like I said, decide to
quit barbering again this week.
So, I'm not necessarily trying to become
a social media influencer and pursue fame
but I've been getting a bunch of jobs
doing commercials for brands,
where they give me creative
freedom, I do my thing,
and like, I'm happy with my life, bro.
I really love it.
- I believe you.
I can feel it.
- Yeah, that's what gives me life is God.
I love it.
- You're also wildly talented.
- I appreciate that.
- Which means you're self sufficient.
- Yeah, for sure, for sure.
And, but the thing is...
- How old are you right now?
- I'm 34, gonna be 35 actually,
I know I look like I'm 14 but
you know, I still got time, I know I do.
- Don't apologize for being handsome.
(laughs)
- I appreciate that.
You know, it's funny,
I'll get into this real
quick, but somebody was like,
"Man, you look like you
could be related to GaryVee,
I was like.
I had a little more of a
beard when they said that but.
- I get it, go ahead.
- I'm a burrito from New Jersey,
I mean, I know you've but you know.
- I love it, same shit.
- So, but I've never been into, you know,
Bentley's or mansions, I hate that crap.
Like, I have no desire for it.
I want freedom to impact
people's lives though,
so, my struggle is,
I don't care about attention anymore,
but I understand you needed
to impact more people
and make more money.
- So good, bro, I do the same thing.
- Yeah.
- I'm not fucking out here
trying to get a star on the Walk of Fame.
I'm not out here trying
to get a private jet
or live that life,
I'm trying to gain attention
so I can do what I wanna do with it,
which is put kindness and
hard work and good traits,
you know, especially for young men,
but for every single human,
I mean, like, good.
like, just because you want to
have followers doesn't mean.
Having followers comes in two forms,
people that do it for themselves
and people that do it for others.
There's a great way to fuckin'
have 10 million followers,
you could you know.
Martin Luther King and Gandhi,
did something different
with their followers
than Madonna did and
neither are wrong or right.
It's just there's a lot of ways to do it.
So, don't apologize for looking
for that quote unquote thing
because it's what you do
with it, not it, itself.
- Right, I agree.
So, besides the video thing
though, like, I also you know,
I wanted to start making like,
I've done it already, I just
haven't launched it yet.
I wanna make like video
transitions, overlays and effects,
to sell to filmmakers
'cause that's the main way
I see financial freedom
from the video side.
- I don't agree with you.
I think the main way to have financial.
Well, first of all do that.
- But what I'm saying is though.
- But I think your financial
freedom comes, dude,
you can sell $300,000 a year in art, easy.
- Right, right.
Well, I'm saying is, I
know a guy who does video,
he makes 100 grand a year doing video.
He started selling his
transitions and effects
and he made a million in one year.
- So do that.
- Off that, yeah.
- If you're excited about it.
Is that million a year
gonna make you happier
than doing 480 doing paintings?
- Well, I mean, either way,
I'm happy with video and art
and I'm having hard (mumbles).
- Great, so do both,
until you figure out which one you like.
- Right.
- It's like dating.
You know, some people leave
that life or they date
until they find the
person they wanna marry.
Like, it's okay to do both.
- Right.
- You have nothing but time
now, you're not cutting hair,
so you got fucking time, do both.
- Well, you know it's
crazy the MTV show they,
it was really guy heavy,
and they had me have a fake girlfriend
because they needed it for the storyline.
- Bro, that's when you should
have fucking quit that shit.
- No, no, no, but listen to this though.
- You fell in love with the girl?
- So, I had (mumbles) my
church who was an artist like,
"hey, can you just be my
fake girlfriend on TV?"
Bro, after the show ends, I
end up falling in love with her
and we get married.
(laughs)
- Hold on.
- Yes, I know, my fake TV
girlfriend became my wife, bro.
- Fuck you Trav.
- I know,
and literally bro, our
whole house looks like this.
Bro, that's a keeper.
Crazy.
- Dude, so the.
How could have you been
upset with the MTV show?
(mumbles)
No, no, stay with me Trav.
You're fucking are mad at the same TV show
when it was the greatest thing
that ever fucking happened to you.
- At the time I was mad at it,
but then after we started dating
then I was like, "Oh Screw it, I'm fine."
(laughs)
- Dude, that is so, bro,
honestly, like cray.
You have things burning down,
your fake girlfriends become your wives.
Bro, you fucking won
dude, you fucking won.
- Gary, my whole life is so God ordained
it's not even funny, listen to this,
I made a video last week
of how I met you, okay.
I was trying to be
creative during quarantine,
and I faked an interview
with you in your office,
but the message of the video
was don't fake it till you make it
and it confused a lot of people
because it looked so real,
even though at the end,
I said I don't know you.
Then a week later, I'm
talking to you for real.
So, people are probably
gonna be confused again
and not believe this.
- Well, it's funny we weren't fucking.
As you were talking some people
in the comments were like,
"Yo, this dude's met Gary already,"
and I'm like, damn, usually
I'm good with fucking,
like, you know, remembering shit.
I was like sitting here thinking like,
Man I really don't remember.
So, that just made me happy
'cause I thought I was
starting to fucking lose it.
- Right no, yeah no, no.
- Trav, you have so much good.
Bro, you have so much good
coming out of your soul.
You have so much good stuff.
Just put out content bro.
How serious are you
about TikTok right now?
- Okay so, when you first
started talking about TikTok
I got on it and I fell off bro,
straight up honest, I know.
No, no, no, I know, I know.
I just, I literally dropped the ball.
I got really into.
- It's such a good spot.
Dude, it's such a good spot for you.
- I know.
- You're such a good energy
for the 16 year olds too,
like the whole thing is so obvious to me.
- Yeah, um, yeah.
Can I ask you a question?
Can you watch the video of me and you
having the interview in your office
and let me know what you think?
- What do I think?
If you tricked fucking
people to think it was real,
it's gonna be fucking amazing.
- It's so real.
I was ripping footage
of when you were talking
about Travis from Uber.
I mean, it's hilarious.
- All right, I will.
Dustin make sure I watch it this week.
Put it into the team
thread, you got that Dustin?
- Yap, I was looking it up right.
- Okay, Dust, don't you love Trav?
Like, don't you, like,
desperately wanna be his friend?
- Yeah.
- (mumbles) on Instagram and
I bugged the crap out of him
trying to get that video to you,
trying to get on the show
and Dustin, I love you.
- Dustin, are you getting bombarded now?
Like, is your whole like.
- of course, he is.
- Like you was getting killed?
- Yeah.
- You getting inappropriate
offers like money and shit?
- No.
- I offered him a "Ninja
Turtles" painting.
- He did, I remember that, it was cool.
- Alright, get out of here Dustin.
- Hey, so I know I gotta wrap
up 'cause you're running long,
but I really listened to your advice
and, you know, I've been driving
the same car for 14 years.
My wife's car is paid off.
We live in the Redneck
ghetto on an acre and a half
'cause our mortgage is only 550 a month.
I'm setting myself up for the GaryVee,
you know, future type of thing.
and I'm not trying to
keep up with the Joneses.
So, thank you for confirming my behavior,
and I know I'm gonna make it and I just.
- You have made it.
It's not even about making it, bro,
you have made it.
- Yeah.
- Like, you've lived a
more interesting life at 34
more than 90% of people live to 100
and you've got talent and
you've got good vibes.
You're good, bro, you're good.
- You know, it's funny because
everything I've ever set
out to do, it's happened,
like, I met every celebrity
I've ever wanted to meet.
I did the MTV thing which they
actually aired it last year,
which is so weird 'cause
someone took a snapshot
and we're like, "you're on TV."
I'm like, "wait a minute,
I thought that whatever."
So, anything I've ever
set out to do, it happens
and I wanted to meet you and
we're talking right now, bro,
and it's just crazy and you know,
before I sign off, I just
wanna tell you this, man,
'cause I really feel
like this is on my heart.
But you know, I wanna tell you this man,
My bible tells me to give
honor where honor is due,
and you have a God-given
talent for motivating people
and having an impact through your content,
and like, I truly believe
we met for a reason,
and I wanna tell you, man, I believe
God has an even bigger
message inside of you
that's gonna impact more
people than you already are,
which is.
- I agree.
- And you're gonna continue
to excel no matter what,
but I'm telling you right now,
I'm literally on my knees,
I'm gonna be praying for you every day
and God is gonna move in your life,
and you're gonna call me
'cause you got my number now.
(laughs)
"Dude, some amazing supernatural things
are happening behind the
scenes since our talk.
What the heck are you praying over there?"
- Keep it going bro.
- It's gonna affect people's eternities,
not just legacy here on earth,
and I'm rooting for you, bro.
I love you man and I
can't thank you enough
for this time with you, seriously.
- I appreciate it, man, I wish you well.
Talk to you soon.
- Thank you, Gary.
- Good kid, all right, let's keep going.
I like the Jersey good vibes.
That was a nice kid, all right,
let's keep it going, Dust.
(laughs)
- Hey, Gary, how are you?
- I'm, well, how are you?
- I'm focused and never finished.
- Good, I like that, what's your name?
- My name is Rob.
- Rob, real pleasure.
- Okay, so I'll give you
a little bit of context.
So, I live in a really small town
here in the Silicon Valley,
called Milpitas, which is
right in front of San Jose,
and if you know anything
about Silicon Valley,
it has like a really
hardcore startup culture,
right?
- Yes.
- And so,
me, I've always had a sort
of entrepreneurial spirit,
I mean, the only thing that
I really wanna do in life,
I mean, nobody can really
convince me otherwise.
I wanna make movies.
Like, that's the only thing,
that's the only shit that
really truly makes me happy.
But the thing with me is
that I'm having a hard time
(sighs) having the discipline
and having the accountability
to really just go for it and.
- Why?
(sighs)
What are you scared of?
And what are the circumstances
of your childhood?
Are you like,
what's stopping you?
Like, if you would get
real fucking real with me.
Like really tell me the actual answer.
'Cause you know, it's
just hard to say out loud.
- Yeah, I'm actually
completely fine with saying it.
I've said it before on my Instagram where.
- Okay, so?
- I think it was about a year ago I had,
I was really, really passionate
about making this short film.
It was part of my graduation requirements,
and we had to make a just
a short 10 minute film.
And so,
I made it and all hell broke loose.
I was super passionate, super,
you know, on top of shit,
and everything just was like (exhales)
just, like the editor,
the editing was bad.
I didn't really like the
camera angles we got.
Everybody's time schedules
is just so constrained
to the point where we
weren't even able to finish.
We had to cut out probably
like 80% of the story.
You know what I mean?
And so that...
- I guess, it didn't go well.
- Didn't pan out.
- Yep, that's good.
(sighs)
- Yep.
- Dude, that's good.
- I, um.
- Stay with me here.
That's good.
Adversity is always the
foundation of success.
You needed that punch in the face,
because you probably came in too hot
and thought you were
fucking Steven Spielberg,
and this was gonna be fucking amazing.
Like, you probably came in too hot.
You probably came in too audacious,
you know, too entitled, too
confident, overconfident,
had an ideology in your head.
You might have even, at
this young of an age,
not done right as a leader,
that might have not known how
to lead the people to success.
You might have taken the framework
of they're working for you,
instead of you're working for them,
'cause you've had this
dream, this ambition.
This has been manifesting in your head.
So, there's almost like this
entitled subconscious
that comes into that.
That those people there, the
editors the filmer like, right,
that they're there for you.
Were in reality, for real
success, you're there for them.
- Yeah.
- And so I don't know, I'm excited.
Like, I'm grateful that
this was such a fuckup,
because you're so young,
and I think it led to a
self reflecting moment.
You've already shared that
out to the world on your Instagram.
Here, you and I are now, I'm proud of you.
You need to view that
as what you deserved.
You weren't good, that's why
it sucked, that's on you.
But that's great,
'cause then you get to look
at what you weren't good at.
- Yeah, you know, I, you know,
I totally agree with you and you know,
I've worked with this
nonprofit chapter, I opened
it on campus and everything,
and so, I had this leading
ability which allowed me,
and look, I mean, I've been
pretty vocal about this,
I fucked up like, probably,
like, way more than a lot of people do.
(laughs)
And just realizing that I'm young
and realizing that I'm
like only 22 years old,
and you know, how.
- You're supposed to fuck up.
(laughs)
Like, nobody came out.
Like, nobody comes out the gate.
Like, I had the great fortune
that I made my fucked up
mistakes when I was a kid.
Right, like, you know,
I think back to the
story where I have $1,000
very early in my baseball
card career and my mom,
I begged my mom to take me to Price Club,
which was the precursor to Costco,
and we got there and the
boxes I wanted to buy
weren't there.
But instead of being disciplined,
and not having the money
burn a hole in my pocket
and just keep it and be patient.
It's me at 13, I went on a spree
and bought a ton of bad cards.
Spent like almost all the
money on these bad cards.
Bad football cards, bad baseball cards,
took them home, opened
it up, got that high.
Loved it, it was like almost the lottery.
But then I had nothing,
I had nothing of value.
and I had to grind all of eighth grade,
like making good trades, selling shit,
to like, get back to even that
point where I had that money,
and that taught me a great lesson.
I had the luxury of learning
a lot of my business lessons.
You know, we don't talk
about business kid prodigies,
but you know if that was a thing,
I would have been one of those.
I learned a lot of things
that six, seven, eight, nine
10, 11, 12, 13, 14, so now
I'm 44 but I'm like 100,
'cause I've been in my
game for fucking 37 years,
which most people don't get into the game
until their mid 20s and
then they're retiring,
I'm in my prime.
I'm in the dawn of my prime.
My prime is probably my 60s.
So, I think this is great that
you fucking have this huge L,
because I think
it is starting to instill
more humility into you,
which is gonna be a balance
that you're gonna need
to be a great movie maker.
- Yeah.
So how do you think,
I should have that
accountability moving forward?
'Cause I totally realize that
and especially after talking to you,
it's just like, now I'm writing
this feature film that I'm doing and
pretty much really starting
to get the ball rolling again.
So, how do I have the accountability?
- First and foremost,
you have to realize that
it was 100% your fault that, that failed,
and that you don't want
that to happen again.
(laughs)
You know, like, you don't
want that to happen.
So, I think one, that should help you.
Two, you should also be okay
when this one gets fucked up,
because maybe you were at 10 audacity,
and maybe as you sit here with
me, you're still at seven,
and you may need another
punch in the fucking neck
to go to four,
like, you know, like,
it's still a process.
But the number one thing
I can tell you brother
is if you're a leader,
you work for them, they
don't work for you.
It's a huge factor,
and I see it a ton in creatives
getting fucked up and getting confused.
It's a huge factor, you work for them.
So, A you have to tell a great story,
but to see that story come into real life,
you're gonna need to be the
number two to your editor.
Number two to the intern
getting coffee for the actors.
You're always playing the humble card,
and I always believe that,
that works out in the end.
I genuinely do,
and so, you have to be
accountable and humble
going into this,
knowing that, that was your vulnerability
the first time around.
- And.
- It's practice.
It's about confidence.
You know who are the dick directors
and the asshole bosses?
The insecure.
- Yeah.
- They need the short term
fix like they're the boss.
But they're, so they win the battle,
like yeah, they belittle somebody,
they can feel better for a quick hit.
But meanwhile, everyone's
talking shit behind their back
and they're not liked and
their legacy is fucked.
- Yeah.
- It's about confidence, go ahead.
- One last thing that I wanna ask you
before we, kind of, cut it off.
If you were GaryVee
and you, instead of GaryVee the media guy,
you were GaryVee, the movie guy,
and this is your first
film out of film school,
and you really wanna
get this film out there.
What is your game plan for that?
- So it's interesting, right?
'Cause I'm going to be GaryVee the video,
the movie guy and the TV guy,
like, I'm gonna make original
content in my career.
My approach to that was to
build a marketing engine
VaynerMedia, that could
be bringing exposure
to every one of my projects
when the time is right.
So, I'm living what you're saying.
I just decided to take a 30
year, 40 year approach to it.
Because my passion was
building the marketing engine,
and then layering it.
For you, your Passion is the movie.
You know, here's what I would say.
I would build a community.
I would you know, if I'm you,
I would network like crazy.
I would join a ton of Facebook groups.
I would start a bunch
of Instagram accounts,
I would comment on people's YouTube.
I would do a ton of homework
on who's winning in Hollywood and New York
and start DMing them and
offer to be an intern.
I would lean into humility
and patience and work ethic,
to build a community,
to then leverage
to bring exposure to
when that film is out.
But let me tell you the
biggest thing I've learned,
kind of, spending time in Hollywood
over the last five years,
kind of, paying attention.
Movie marketing is garbage.
People are really bad at marketing movies.
- Oh, yeah?
- You know, really bad at it.
They do not use the
modern platforms and so.
Listen, my game is very simple.
Whether you're trying
to cure Crohn's disease,
or whether you're trying
to raise money for the PTA,
or whether you're trying to
help one 16 year old girl
who's on the verge of
making tough decisions.
I believe that the internet
is the most powerful
medium to reach people,
and I think whatever sites or apps
are winning on top of the
internet at the moment,
whether that's podcasts or YouTube,
whether it's TikTok or LinkedIn,
being a storyteller within
all those platforms matters.
You know, I'll give you an example.
It's about creativity.
One thing I would do if
I was writing a movie,
I would probably start an account
of the lead character in that film
two years before the film came,
as you're writing the story,
and we create a character
named Benjamin Thompson,
I would literally create
an Instagram account
for Benjamin Thompson.
Find some artists like the one I just had
on social media, and literally, literally
DM like 50 artists and be like,
"hey, if you create this character with me
and do all the drawings
and the comic strip
or the pictures or whatever,
you know, when I make my movie,
I'll give you a half a
point 0.5% of the back end,
if that ever takes,"
like, just being creative,
just being thoughtful, like,
and God forbid,
that, that Instagram account
gets a little traction,
it leads to a narrative when
the film comes out, like so.
There's just a lot of
creative ways to do shit.
The bottom line though, is,
and it's so obvious to me, brother,
this is a game of patience,
and putting in the work.
Like, you know, when you're
an aspiring filmmaker,
you dream every day, it's in your soul
for you to have your breakout film.
You watch the fucking
Oscars and you see highlight
and you're like, that's gonna be me.
You see a break, right,
you know what I mean?
Like I get it, but like the reality is,
it takes a lot grinding time.
A lot.
- Yeah, I mean, the only
luxury we have is time, right?
- Yeah, and then other people be like,
time is fleeting and you never know.
and I get all that, but
like, the reality is,
whether you think we have
a ton of time or no time.
Whichever one you believe
in, I can promise you this,
the fucking hard work
is the cost of entry.
You either have such
extreme, God-given talent,
that the first thing you write
pops off on some Matt Damon,
you know, and Ben Affleck shit, right?
Or you're like the 99%
and you put in the fucking two decades,
and then your moment comes.
Take it from a 44 year
old who's twice your age.
If I told you right now,
you have to put in 22 years of
grinding, but at 44 you hit,
you would fucking rip your
arm off for that opportunity.
Yet when you're 22 that
sounds like the worst.
- Yeah, it does sound.
Sounds so far away
but that's what it takes, right?
- It definitely is normally
a foundational piece of the
required way to get there.
But here's my thing,
being a filmmaker
that is commercially successful
enough to live your life,
is such a lottery ticket,
it should be hard.
I keep reminding all my friends
and youngsters in this
community, it's like,
wait a minute, let me get this straight,
you wanna be a millionaire?
You know, less than a
1% of 1% kind of life?
Shouldn't that be hard?
Shouldn't that take a long time?
Shouldn't it be really
difficult, you know?
- Right.
- You know, like,
shouldn't that require an
enormous amounts of time?
Shouldn't that, like, be a process like,
I'm always trying to
get people to understand
what they're actually asking for.
Are you out of your mind?
There's only so many
filmmakers in the world.
You wanna live that life?
Cool.
But of course it should
be fucking bleeding
out of your eyeballs.
Of course, there should
be unlimited roadblocks.
Of course, this should be hard.
- Yeah.
I see what you mean.
- All right.
- Alright, Gary.
Yeah
- Good luck, bro.
- One last thing, can
I just grab this clip?
- Yeah, of course.
- Yeah.
- Yes.
- Okay.
- Work with Dustin, all right.
- Awesome, thanks very much.
- You got it.
- Bye, bye.
- Danny.
- Hey, Gary.
- How are you?
- I'm amazing, this is amazing.
Thank you so much for this opportunity.
- Can you hold on one
second, yeah, you got it.
Can you hold one second?
Hey, Dustin.
- Yep.
- Are you personally
gonna apologize to Sarah
who thought she had a
hundredth of a second moment?
- I'm sorry, Sarah. I clicked.
- It's clearly, she's
not gonna get in today.
You gave her 100 of a second of hope,
but then you took it away
like the Grim Reaper,
are you gonna personally apologize?
- But on the hindsight,
she'll be first tomorrow.
(laughs)
- Get out of here, Danny.
- Yeah, not gonna lie,
I had a mini freakout,
I was like, "Oh, oh no."
(laughs)
Thanks so much for this opportunity,
and I'll try and be brief.
You know, and just as someone who
feeds off the inspiration of others,
certainly you are someone that is
endless source of inspiration to me,
so thank you for that.
- You got it Danny, thank you.
- So, just quickly, a little backstory.
So, I am originally from St. Louis,
but I'm a musician and a drummer composer.
That's been my whole life
since my earliest memories of being alive,
and it's all I've ever really
wanted to do with my life.
And so, I moved to the city,
NewYork City, for college
and studied music.
And that's just always been my whole life.
It's my biggest passion.
Never been a question about that.
And so recently,
I started making these
short clips for Instagram,
where I would compose a baseline,
and I would improvise on drums over that.
And so, without trying
to be too technical here,
a lot of the concepts that
I worked with in college
were just very advanced
technical music concepts,
specifically advanced
rhythms and things like that.
So, some of the stuff that, you know,
my community was working on a lot
and sort of studying a lot, is not as,
I don't wanna say accessible,
but it's not as known to.
- Make sense.
- Yeah, right.
- This is super cliche.
You know, as you were talking, I'm like,
this reminds me of the wine world.
You know, everybody is so nerdy
and get so fucking deep,
that they made wine not
accessible to Americans,
and what I did with Wine Library TV,
was made wine accessible for the youth
and the Americans in general,
and that's why it worked.
Because to your point, you know,
you out nerded the field,
and they couldn't understand the value
even if they heard it.
- Right, well, and I mean,
I think that's, kind of, where
this little niche for me came in because,
I started making these clips and
you know, they were.
I mean, I was doing
them because I was like,
okay, this is something I like to do,
and it also kind of showcases
my musical influences in
the direction I'm going,
but it's also just a form of content
that people might find engaging.
And so, it was working
really well on Instagram.
So, I started putting it
in these Facebook groups,
and they're, you know,
these like sub genres
that sort of relate to the,
kind of, music that I work on,
and they really took off there.
So, I started putting them in Reddit,
and then they really took off
there and then COVID happened,
and so I'm like, okay,
I've been meaning to start a
YouTube channel for a while now
of this kind of content.
- Good.
- And like, you know, I mean,
I actually had the channel for a while
and didn't really do anything
with it and just was hard to.
I just didn't prioritize it enough.
And so, basically my
question is more or less,
this channel, there's a lot
of music channels out there,
a lot of drum lessons, things like that.
This stuff is so...
- But there's no Danny YouTube channel.
- Right, exactly, exactly.
And I part of it is...
- The end.
- This stuff is kinda weird.
- Yeah, the end.
- Mm hmm.
- Like, you know,
there's there's an ungodly
amount of content in every genre.
There's unlimited people
that talk about mindset
and business stuff like me.
There's unlimited people
that do wine content,
there's unlimited everything.
There's no, nobody's
making up anything new.
The only thing is...
- Very, very true.
- The only new or unique
thing is the human behind it.
- Hundred percent, hundred percent agree
and that's, kind of, part
of the thing that helped me
be very motivated about it, is I'm like,
well, I'm kind of a specific character
and like maybe the
combination of the music
and just whatever other
attributes are in these clips,
it's gonna be something
people resonate with,
and then that kind of was bolstered by
those things doing well on
Facebook and Reddit and stuff.
- I love that.
- So and, you know, career wise,
I make all my money off
of playing or teaching
and I love both.
- I love that, good.
- And so that was, it
was kind of a win win.
I'm like, well, I started this channel
and then that will bring
attention to me as a teacher
and also as performer, etc.
So, my general question is, you know,
finding the niche that I
resonate with was easy on Reddit
and on Instagram and Facebook,
just because it's very clear cut like,
"oh, go here, post right here
and all the people that are
into this will check it out."
With YouTube, I feel like the
day that I started the channel
and told my people to
come over to it, they did,
and you know, like overnight
I might have gotten 50 or 60 people,
now I've got maybe about 130 subscribers,
but I'm trying to figure out how to reach,
like, this niche is small
but not the smallest.
- They're gonna.
Do it by your titles and descriptions,
people are gonna search, the end.
- Yeah, that's what I'm working
on and I'm constantly...
- I think what you need to work on
is being okay with slow growth,
when you had quick growth
in the other platforms.
- Hundred percent.
Hundred percent, yeah,
YouTube clearly does
not work the same way.
and I do, I'm constantly
watching these videos (mumbles).
- Where are you on TikTok?
Because I know you
didn't have the audacity
to come on the show and
not have your TikTok ready.
- Okay so, initially,
I started a TikTok for
my band Horse Torso,
and then,
(laughs)
you like that?
- It's a great name.
Yeah, I like that name.
- Yeah, my wife came up
with that name.
- Love that name.
- So, initially I was posting there
and then I started this other channel.
But so, I watched a lot of TikTok,
tried to kind of figure
out how to cater to it.
I was posting the same.
I was posting basically the same content
I had been posting on the other platforms,
and it just wasn't taking off on TikTok,
so admittedly, briefly, I paused TikTok,
but then I set up another TikTok
that's for my specific channel,
it's got the same name as my
YouTube channel, Youdiments.
- What is that, spell
that so people can follow.
- It's Y-O-U-D-I-M-E-N-T-S.
So, it's like rudiments,
so in drumming, there's
a thing called rudiments,
which are patterns that
drummers practice to,
you know, get their technique together.
So, the concept of
youdiments is basically like,
my
take is that,
a thing we really weren't
taught in school is that,
not only should you learn all
these things that were set by,
you know, the history of playing music,
but we should also be examining
what we do naturally well,
and the things that work well for us
and we should be doubling down
on practicing what works for us,
in addition to studying all the patterns
that are within the tradition of drumming.
- I like it.
- Thanks, so yeah, so,
and I did get that URL
so it's, yeah, exactly.
It's
YouTube backslash youdiments.
And now I'm getting notifications already.
So, yeah, so basically
the thing with TikTok is
I feel like I haven't
mastered the format because,
for Reddit then Facebook
and all those things...
- There's only one way
to master the format.
It was the same way that you
mastered your drum skill.
You have to fucking practice.
And the only reason you're giving up
is it's not coming as
quickly as you'd like it to.
- Hundred percent and I've
only been doing it for
I don't know,
six weeks or something
with the YouTube channel
- And six weeks into YouTube,
a couple weeks into TikTok
and you're not where you
theoretically wish you were,
from a numbers standpoint
and you fucking bounce.
- Right, right no, I
mean, you're right it's.
- I know I'm right.
I know I'm right.
- Yeah.
- And I know that you understand it
because you would have never
been great at what you do
if you didn't put an
obnoxious amount of work
and six months in have a breakthrough
and two years in have a breakthrough
and four years in have a breakthrough.
For your genre,
TikTok and YouTube really
fucking matter, bro.
- Mm hmm.
Yeah, I'm trying my hand at TikTok again,
and I won't let up
until I see some growth.
- Or until, no, no.
You won't let up until you.
It's not about seeing growth,
it's about loving the
process, not the numbers.
I promise you the single most
awareness post of your career
will happen on TikTok in the
next six months, I promise.
- Wow, I mean, that's, you know, I'm.
I mean, you were my inspiration
to start it in the first place.
I had not, I don't think
I had even heard of it
until you mentioned it.
And yeah, and you know, I do, that's
the thing is that I really do enjoy
the process of making
the content and making,
you know, like all of like, for YouTube
and for the other platforms.
And it is a win, win for
me because it's like,
I wanna just bring awareness,
like I said to myself,
as a drum instructor,
and it (mumbles).
- I got it, you got, bro,
you've got everything right,
you just need to make more content.
- Hundred percent, hundred percent.
- I wish you well bro.
- I totally agree.
Thanks so much, Gary.
Again, It means a lot
- you got bro, you got it.
- Just spending time with you, thank you.
- Take care.
- You too.
- All right Dustin,
good show, right, like
just, kind of, like a
solid right down the pike, kind of, show.
I'm going to now hang up
and write today's wine text,
'cause it is the single
best peanut in the world
we've ever offered,
and I want you guys to
sign up for my podcast
and my new Twitter Channel, GaryVeeTV,
GaryVee TV, Gary V-E-E TV,
and thank you for watching
and I appreciate it,
and I'll see you tomorrow.
The people that are gonna win
over the next five to seven years,
are gonna be very comfortable
in controlled fucking chaos.
(epic music)
You don't love the process.
This is dreams we're talking about.
Dreams require sacrifice.
All of your actions
have to then map to it.
(mumbles) Backpack, backpack, backpack.
Nobody gives a shit
about where you grew up.
The whole game is scaling the unscalable.
It's fucking hard work,
it's being respectful,
it's being a good person.
Do that, that's just a good idea.
It's there, the flipman is there.
This house right here, there's $400.
I stay in my lane, like
real fucking tight,
but you can't be crippled.
Everybody here is judging themselves.
You're looking at what's
in front of you right now.
You're losing 'cause
you're laying in your bed
looking at somebody's fucking glamorous,
photoshopped picture, of
them doing something cool,
and you're envious, and you're
jealous and you're impatient,
and it's crippling your upside.
Let me just say one more
time if you're confused,
what I just said.
I say put your fucking flag on the ground
of who the fuck you are.
Whoever provides the
most value always wins.
You're entering the greatest
five year window of your life.
My only answer to anybody
like is just like, try shut.
Shut your business down and go work
for an apparel company for 10 years.
Nobody you've ever met
got there without the hard work.
So you better get your speed up.
You better work harder,
you better work smarter.
If you can't Google stuff,
you're not gonna be able to do anything,
but I'm telling bro, GaryVee TV,
my Google account, check
me out, hope you enjoy it.
(upbeat music)